henry chapier bonsoir baudracco gamme
suis bien là alors apparemment les
responsables du festival ont décidé de
jouer cette année la carte nombre
d'auteurs et nouveaux talents non tout à
fait mais vous savez le 41e s'équivalent
ne ressemble à aucun autre on le voit
déjà
d'abord on a décidé parce que leurs
graves de prendre le cinéma au sérieux
et des lignes et un peu ce qui nous fait
oublier la raison de ce grand
rassemblement des gens qui est bas et
bien on vient vraiment cette année pour
découvrir des films alors jusqu'à
présent on est un peu blasés
parce qu' on ne pouvait plus trouver à
cal que très rarement dans les palmarès
au delà des palmarès les nouvelle
cinématographie
on s'était un peu trop habitués à voir
le l'éternel tiercé gagnant
les etats unis la france ou l'italie
et bien cette année nous allons
connaître des surprises je pense et
c'est al côté européen beaucoup plus
fort qu autrefois mais aussi des films
d'asie d'afrique et d'ailleurs
mais alors il y à aussi dans une soirée
d'ouverture des images que l'on connaît
on a vu la montée des marches
ceux qui ne l'ont pas vu sur notre
chaîne jusqu'à présent pourront toujours
contempler les quelques mots manquent
traditionnel de monter vers sa septième
ciel qu'est le cinéma ce sont évidemment
des scènes d'ouverture traditionnel mais
l'esprit n'est pas tout à fait le même
alors ça m'amène à vous parler du film
d'ouverture qui lui aussi était attendu
avec énormément d'impatience
personne ne l'avait vu ce grand bleu de
luc besson
et bien c'est une aventure dont beaucoup
d'adolescents ont rêvé et pas seulement
puisque c'est l'histoire d'une plongée
en apnée un thème que vous
connaissez peut-être bien ou peut-être
pas c'est la plongée sous marine jusqu'à
la limite de la résistance humaine
c'est-à-dire qu'au lieu de se servir de
la fameuse bouteille on prend une grande
respiration mais essayez si vous y
arrivez à 4 cm de profondeur c'est pas
évident vous pouvez y perdre votre vie
alors au delà de ses exploits téméraire
luc besson évidemment a voulu aussi une
symbolique vous souvenez sans doute de
subway est bien subway c'est à dire le
métro en français vous avez peut-être vu
son film en tout cas et coupé le duc
beso en train de vous expliquer pourquoi
il a fait ce film là il y avait un
besoin d'en parler de ça c'est sûr et
quand j'ai décidé un peu plus tard de
faire du cinéma j'ai un peu lié les deux
choses mais j'avais envie de parler du
grand bleu avant même de savoir que je
voulais faire du cinéma quoi en bleu
pour certains c'est un peu déconcertant
parce qu'il ya plusieurs sujets il n'y a
pas que celui là qui n'aboutissent pas
tout je vous le dis tout de suite mais
les avis sont partagés
e il faut peut-être aussi apporter un
éclairage des formations
professionnelles de divan un peu
psychanalytique
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent le besson je
pense qu'au delà de l'aventuré ils
demandent pourquoi les gens vont comme
ça au fond de la mer
ils vont chercher simplement quelque
chose un secret sur nos origines
c'est en quelque sorte pour les
personnages de luc besson si le retour à
l'état antérieur celui où nous étions
presque tous dans le ventre de maman
c'est une explication qui vaut ce
qu'elle vaut je voudrais à présent quand
même attirer votre attention sur le
président du jury qui est ettore scola
ça vous dit certainement beaucoup de
choses notamment la journée particulière
un film qui a très bien marché en france
et dernièrement l'année
bref la famille et bien être et scola
est un grand défenseur du cema européen
simplement le film de luc besson qu'on a
vu ce matin était en anglais est alors
beaucoup de gens se sont posé la
question pourquoi pas la raison est
simple c'est qu'on n'a pas assez
d'argent toujours il faut faire donc
appel à des financements extérieurs et
en l'occurrence un financement avec bon
dans le cas de la plupart des films
européens d'aujourd'hui ont réuni les
efforts de plusieurs pays et on trouve
cet éternel licence de doublage
quelle est vraiment la version d'origine
à la fille mais comment arriver à ce
casting garde ce côté nationale qui nous
plaît tant eh bien écoutez et en escale
à lui même
vous parlez de la comédie du doublage
ça vaut son pesant d'or h&m américains
qui dans l'histoire qui arrive de naples
qui parle avec un napolitain qui connaît
un peu rendrait est donc dans cette
somme là le sait le napolitain qui
traduisent que la mère dit en napolitain
à l'américain lamont nous avons que
jacques raymond américain est doublée en
français très très bien je dois dire
perdre 6 mendy qui a fait un très bon
travail mais il parle français
mme astriam et par le français il se
doubler lui même et la mer talent
français
alors tout le monde à le faire assez et
on sait pas bien pourquoi l'américaine
de mal qu'est ce qu'elle dit et alors il
devrait comprendre ce qui va leur être
mais sait on est en train d'essayer de
faire la mère qui parle en français un
peu un peu à peu un peu patois comme ça
l'américain qui connaît très bien le
français qu'elle sait piermont
d'équipage et soient justifiées qui
demandent qu'est-ce que le dire alors
c'est ça le travail que l'on peut faire
c'est drôle évidemment mais ettore scola
est quand même optimiste en ce qui
concerne l'avenir du cinéma
alors il est intéressant de vous dire
que la séquence que vous venez de voir
et celle qui va suivre
nous l'avons tourné à rome il y a un an
dans un atelier où et tresco la forme
tout à fait volontairement bénévolement
des jeunes des jeunes qui vont devenir
évidemment des signal
pourquoi parce qu'il a confiance dans
cette jeune génération et laissons lui
le dire mieux que personne pourquoi à
l'avenir bien parce que notre génération
wii a fait tellement de choses telles
que quelques joints sur de bonnes choses
mais comme bilange là je pense que
nous avons à nous reprocher quelques
responsabilités quelques
quelque chose qui nous n'avons pas fait
peut-être que nous pouvions faire
quelquefois un manque de sérénité
quelquefois et manque de responsabilité
peut-être qu'on a été même spécialement
parmi les intellectuels un peu trop
égotiste un peu trop on a pensé plus tôt
à lundi un autre individu ou que la
connectivité et le jus les jeunes je
pense que cela mieux reçus dans les
familles que dans la société aussi même
les hommes de gouvernement que je le
gall de chaque jour à la télé qui sont
toujours là dédia 40 ans et sont
toujours les mêmes je n'ai plus
confiance à peut-être que je n'ai plus
confiance
la majoration d'un dans le chou grille
je sais pas mais j'ai beaucoup plus
confiance 15 jours à hambye sage jeunes
envisagent sarid câblerie de quelle
façon le montre aussi des rides
intérieur qui je ne dis pas qu'il ne
rompent pas mais pour le moment ils ne
les ont pas en conclusion de cette
soirée j'aimerais vous dire que la vraie
compétition commence demain avec
l'oeuvre au noir d'après marguerite
yourcenar un film d'andré delvaux
j'aimerais vous dire aussi que vous
devez rester avec nous ce soir parce que
dans hot yannick on parle encore et
toujours de cinéma avec amour et
compétences à demain merci henri chapier
et peu